The basic narrative of human struggle,
his oppressor versus oppressed,
we use category structures,
can constrain that infinite number of
interpretations because the basic
narrative is an oppressor versus
oppressed.
We choose those narratives that serve
our function as old pressers,
so it's deeply cynical but credible,
you know,
and you can say if you're not naive that
people are motivated by power and that
our interpretations of the world can be
self serving.
I mean we do want to serve ourselves
after all because otherwise we die and
so and we are centered in one place and
so we can't see everything and we're
biased.
So.
So there is the probability that the way
that we look at the world will be
tainted by narrow self interest and
maybe even tainted by ingroup interests
beyond narrow,
individual self interested.
We know this is true,
but it's also not all bad.
You know,
like we a good person takes care of his
or her family.
What does that mean?
It means you prefer your family.
Outsiders,
you were going to get rid of that.
It's a form of prejudice.
Like it really is like your choice of
sexual partners,
a form of prejudice,
right?
I mean maybe it should be distributed in
an egalitarianism manner.
Hey,
that would be a lot funnier if it isn't
a possibility like in,
in,
in Huxley's brave new world,
that was the rule you,
you shared yourself with whoever asked
because it was rude not to and you know
what it is actually rude not to.
It's seriously rude.
Now,
is that something you want to take away
from people?
You want that to be distributed in an
egalitarianism fashion.
How prejudiced you when you choose
someone to sleep with you choose that
person and not everyone else.
It's the ultimate in prejudice.
If you say,
well,
that's not prejudicial.
Oh yes,
it is.
Usually go for the most attractive
partner you can find.
Usually go for the healthiest partner.
You go for the best person you can find
who can tolerate you.
It's prejudicial in every possible way
so well,
so okay,
so your self serving and you construct a
view of the world that serves those
selfserving causes and some of that has
to do with power.
Fair enough.
That doesn't mean it all has to do with
power
though.
It means that some of it has to do with
power.
It's like racism.
People are kind of racist or maybe
people prefer their ingroup.
It's not that easy.
Or maybe people prefer the familiar to
the novel.
You know that I eat that the social
psychologists have come up with implicit
association test that measures
unconscious bias.
We don't know what the hell that
measures the people who invented that
bloody thing.
They know.
We don't know what it measures.
They know it's not reliable.
They know it's not valid enough to be
used as an individual diagnostic
instrument.
That's technically the case.
They also know that you can't train
people out of their unconscious biases
because there is not much difference
between unconscious bias and
instantaneous perception,
but they don't really care.
I've.
I've written to Missouri and Banerji.
He's one of the inventors of the IAT
several times saying,
how about you come out in public and say
what you already know?
Which is that people are misusing your
damn test.
Silence.
Well,
that's partly because her discipline,
social psychology is a corrupt
discipline as the social psychologists
have discovered over the last four
years,
can be turning themselves inside out,
trying to rectify which they haven't
anyways,
we're giving the devil his due.
There's an infinite number of
interpretations of the world and it's
highly probable that you'll lay a self
serving one on top of it.
Yes,
and also that will serve the interests
of your group,
however you define that,
yes,
but it only accounts for a fraction of
your behavior.
There's all sorts of other things at
work as well,
and you don't get to reduce all human
motivations to one motivation power,
and then you might also ask,
well,
why would you want to reduce all human
motivations to power it so you can use
power?
That's why you can justify the use of
power.
That's force.
You don't have to engage in civilized
debate.
You don't have to give a damn about the
facts,
especially if you're not a postmodernist
because you don't believe in facts
anyways.
And you might ask,
well,
why don't you?
Hey,
I'm not kidding.
Postmodernists don't believe in facts.
They believe that the idea of fact is
part of the power game that's placed
played by the white dominated male
patriarchy to impose the theoretical
structure of the Patriarchy on the
oppressors.
It's like I'm not making this stuff up.
It's embedded,
right?
In theory,
all you have to do is read it and you
find this out so they don't believe in
facts.
While facts would constrain the use of
power,
at least that's how it looks to me.
Okay,
so fine.
We gave the devil his due.
There's an infinite number of
interpretations and you're likely to use
bias compression algorithms on the world
and they're likely to be biased in your
favor.
True,
but
only partly true.
And the difference between India log and
the thinker is that a thinker knows the
difference between things that are only
partly true and things that are
completely true.
Things are complicated.
Like I like to think everything is as
complicated as a military helicopter.
You have to like.
I think it's eight hours of maintenance
to keep those things in the air for one
because they don't fly there rocks.
They plummet.
It's really hard to keep them in the air
and they're full of parts and if you
don't know all those parts,
you don't go in there and monkey about
with them because they just wreck it and
that's just a helicopter,
like everything is way more complicated
than the helicopter,
so you don't just go muck about in there
hoping you're going to make it better.
That isn't how it works.
You need to be competent.
Alright,
so look,
here's where the postmodernists are
wrong.
I think there's three places and they're
serious errors.
The first is that there is an infinite
number of interpretations,
but there is not an infinite number of
viable interpretation.
So there's a very finite number of
viable interpretations and I don't think
that this is theory.
I think that game theorists have already
demonstrated this to some degree and
it's going to be built into AI systems
very rapidly.
Okay?
So what are the constraints?
First of all,
you can't have an interpretation that
leads to immediately to your death or
your dad.
Now,
if you want to be dead,
that's fine,
but if you don't want to be,
then you got a lot of limited options,
right?
You don't get to run naked across an
eight lane freeway at night blindfolded
because probably you'll be dead.
That's a bad interpretation.
Okay,
so you might say because you're fragile
and vulnerable and mortal,
that there's a limited number of ways
that you can look at the world that
don't result in,
let's say death or serious damage or
agony.
That's a bad thing.
Agony is a bad thing.
Most people agreed on that.
So you're constrained by pain and
anxiety.
At least your interpretations are
constrained by pain and anxiety and you
know you can make pain worse or better
by thinking about it to some degree,
but only to some degree.
When push comes to shove,
pain is your master.
Okay?
So that's a big constraint.
That's a big,
big constraint.
Well,
but the constraints are worse than that
because not only do you not
get to have an interpretation of the
world that produces anxiety and
suffering right now,
but you don't get to have an
interpretation of the world that if you
iterate it across time produces pain and
suffering and so that's,
that's a big problem because there's
lots of.
You could go out tonight and get
yourself blind drunk on cocaine and
sleep with six hookers and you know,
maybe that maybe that'd be a good night.
You know,
you might not think about it being so
good tomorrow,
but then maybe your dad have aids in a
year or maybe you're addicted to cocaine
or maybe you're a street alcoholic or
whatever.
It's like as an iterable game,
that's a downhill.
And the thing is you play iterated
games.
You don't play one,
you play iterated games and so your
interpretation of the world has to be
one that will sustain multiple
iterations across time because you have
to worry about 40 year old you and 60
year old you.
And that's a big problem.
That's a lot of used,
stretched over a long period of time and
it's worse than that because it's not
just you,
it's like you and your right and not
only so.
Not only do you have to take care of
yourself now in a manner that allows you
to take care of yourself when you're 40,
you have to take care of yourself now in
a manner that takes care of you when
you're 40 so that other people are happy
to have you around now and continually
so that they'll cooperate and compete
with you in a positive way,
and so that's getting ridiculously
complicated.
It's not just you now when you in the
future,
it's you surrounded by other people
doing the same thing now and in the
future and there's a lot of other
people.
It can even just be you and your family.
You know,
like like the psychopathic burglar mob
that's just not going to go so well,
right?
Other people are going to object and the
world's going to object and so fine.
There's an infinite number of
interpretations,
but it doesn't mean there's an infinite
number of viable interpretations.
In fact,
there are hardly any,
there are hardly any playable games.
Now,
piaget,
the developmental psychologist who's a
very smart guy,
he pointed out something very
interesting.
He said,
imagine you ran a set of iterated games
as a competition and in one iterated
game the rule was you bloody well do
what I tell you to.
And the other one is,
well,
we'll all get together and decide how
we're going to do this.
Okay,
now we run the competition.
Uh,
Piaget's claim is you do what I tell you
fails.
And the reason for that is I have to
impose force in order to keep you
cooperating.
And the imposition of forest is a cost.
It's an efficiency cost.
And across time that efficiency cost is
going to multiply.
And the equilibrated state solution,
which is the one where we all agree it
wins.
Now that's worth thinking about and you
can think about that locally.
So you've got,
you're trying to organize your family,
you have a little family conference
about who's doing what in the household
and what do you.
If you want peace and harmony and an
iterated game,
you get everybody to say,
well,
here's the tasks and we have to be done.
People have to rely on that and then you
say,
well,
which tasks would you do?
You have to some how about you and you
know which task would you do and
everybody agrees and then you say,
well,
unless you can come up with a better
solution,
that's the one we're going to go with,
and then people can be a little
resentful and angry about the conditions
of existence where they have to work,
but they can't really blame that on
anyone else and maybe that's the best
solution you can come up with.
And that was piaget's idea of the
equilibrium state.
It was like it's a voluntary agreement
that can be iterated across time.
That works at multiple levels of social
organization.
Man,
that's a serious,
serious,
serious set of constraints.
And Piaget,
by the way,
was looking for a way to reconcile
science and religion.
He was looking for biological origin to
morality and he thought he found it in
the idea of the equilibrium state and
it's even deeper than that.
So imagine this equilibrium state ideas.
Actually there's something to it that if
you set the the state of property,
it will iterate across time so long that
it becomes a permanent part of the
environment.
Hierarchy is exactly.
That's exactly what a hierarchies.
Hierarchies are $350,
million years old.
They are not the patriarchal invention
of white European Christian males in the
last 300 years.
There are $350 million years old.
They're stable,
they're stable solutions to this
iterated game problem and they've been
around so long that we're actually
adapted to the and that's part of the
reason we have archetypal
representations of the social structure.
So and then we also have archetypal
representations of the relationship of
the individual to the social structure.
Your job as an individual in
relationship to the social structure is
to embody the social structure,
but also to serve as as its eyes and its
mouth.
So that can update itself wouldn't
necessarily.
So you take on the mantle of your
father,
let's say,
but he's dead.
He's the path he can't see.
You can see,
so you take the structure that's already
there and you modify it where it's
necessary and that modification process
is necessary or the state becomes too
static and collapses and that's why the
state has to be subordinate to the
individual and that's what Western
culture has discovered and we can't just
let it go.
That's the idea.
The logos,
that's a big idea and you'd want to live
somewhere where you want to live
somewhere where the individual is
subordinate to the state.
It's like,
hey,
go right ahead.
There's lots of places like that,
man,
emigrate go there.
Ninety percent of the world's countries
are like that.
If you want to live like that,
man,
go find out what it's like.
You don't see immigration going there,
that's for sure.